[Música]
han estado en alguna comida con sus
amigos familiares y se ponen a hablar de
negocios se ponen a crear una empresa y
ya saben dónde comprar ya saben dónde
vender ya saben hasta cuánto dinero van
a ganar y están pensando hasta en dónde
se lo van a gastar y al día siguiente se
levantan y no pasa nada
yo he estado en muchas de estas comidas
pero primeramente vale la pena emprender
y tienes lo que se requiere para
emprender estoy aquí para contarles como
yo entré en este camino y darles un par
de consejos que les pueden ayudar
primeramente me gustaría definir tres
elementos que todos tenemos que nos
ponen en igualdad de condiciones que nos
ponen en una cancha pareja
estos tres elementos es tiempo energía y
conocimiento porque la mayoría de los
emprendedores ni tuvieron suerte ni se
sacaron la lotería ni heredaron ni estar
ahí por casualidad están por su esfuerzo
y su sacrificio
tiempo todos tenemos 24 horas al día y
yo tengo más tiempo que ustedes y
ustedes tienen más tiempo que yo a
menudo el tiempo lo vemos como recurso
abundante y limitado y no le damos la
importancia y empiezan a pasar los días
meses años
energía todos tenemos una cantidad
limitada de energía del día y tenemos
que pensar en que lo vamos a emplear es
que todas las actividades que son
mentalmente demandantes o físicamente
demandantes como estudiar estar
concentrado hacer deporte consume mucha
energía
y nos sentimos más cómodos con
actividades que no requieren tanto
esfuerzo el problema es que la energía
que no consume es en un día se
desaprovecha no se almacena el día
siguiente no puedes hacer el doble el
día siguiente se se muere
conocimiento el conocimiento de la
información y experiencia que nos deja
tomar decisiones conocimiento no lo
puedes comprar no puedes ir a una
librería pagar por un libro y decir ya
tengo conocimiento tienes que dedicarle
tiempo energía para digerir para
aprender ese libro
estos tres elementos tienen que estar
alineados para conseguir lo que queremos
si eres joven tienes mucho tiempo tienes
mucha energía pero tienes poco
conocimiento y difícilmente vas a poder
llegar lejos por tanto es muy importante
que desde ahora tengas tu enfoque en el
enfoque es la visión general y luego
ideas detallando en metas y objetivos
específicos pero este enfoque tiene que
ser tu brújula y el norte de esa brújula
debe de apuntar a lo que más anhela si
quieres
muchas veces pensamos en este enfoque
como algo para después ya lo haremos
pero mientras tanto estamos navegando
sin rumbo y el que no sabe adónde va
adónde va a llegar
tenemos que tener enfoque es muy
importante en lo personal en lo
profesional en los hobbies te quieres
casar quieres tener hijos a qué te
quieres dedicar quieres emprender qué
deporte te gusta hacer quieres viajar
por el mundo tú decides pero a partir de
ahí equilibra tu tiempo tu energía y tu
conocimiento en una plática cómo está
una persona decía valora tu tiempo dale
un valor económico a tu tiempo valor
alto piensa en grande puede ser siendo
dable es la hora 200 dólares la hora 50
dólares la hora y ponte cuantificar
todas las actividades que haces al día
que no te aportan un videojuego redes
sociales series 3 horas vamos a suponer
tres horas por 100 dólares 300 dólares
diarios al final de la semana son dos
mil dólares
y vas a estar pensando si carlos pero yo
no gano dos mil dólares a la semana pero
cuando llegue el momento cuando llegue
la oportunidad y no tengas el
conocimiento la experiencia y la
información necesaria para tomar una
decisión
ahí lo vas a pagar no te lo van a cobrar
simplemente no vas a poder agarrar la
oportunidad no la vas a ver a lo mejor
ni cuenta te vas a dar y vas a estar
culpando
el destino que tú no tuviste las
condiciones como otros o la suerte que
otros tuvieron
cuando yo me gradué me fui a trabajar
con mi papá
y sentí que no había aprendido lo
suficiente yo quería emprender quería
crear pero no sabía cómo me sentía
abrumado pasaron cuatro años y había
aprendido muchas cosas pero seguía
teniendo este sentimiento de que me
faltaban cosas por aprender me puse a
pensar que podía hacer y hasta ese
momento nadie mi familia había hecho una
maestría y muchas veces dar ese primer
paso romper esos moldes esas creencias
personales o culturales no está fácil ni
nadie me pedí a mí una maestría yo ya
tenía trabajo
sin embargo mire mi brújula y me atreví
llega a mi casa hablé con mis papás a
casa de mis papás
y todo lo que había ahorrado en estos
cuatro años que llevaba trabajando lo
invertí en mi maestría al terminar la
maestría había conocido gente muy
inteligente que venía de diferentes
industrias
y sentí que tenía que prepararme más
agarre un trabajo este trabajo me saca
de emera de confort porque era una
ciudad lejos diferente donde no conocía
a nadie no tenía amigos no tenía familia
y empezar de cero
y tampoco en el trabajo mejor pagado
pero sí donde yo pensé que más podía
aprender
prioricé mi tiempo mi energía y mi
conocimiento después de unos años vino
la oportunidad yo llevaba mucho tiempo
hablando con mis hermanos a ver qué
podíamos hacer pero no sabíamos que ni
cómo ni cuándo y ahí en una de esas
comidas soñadoras junto con el mejor
amigo de mi hermano vivo en nuestra
oportunidad y la tomamos dudé no me
sentí abrumado no me sentí preparado
absolutamente porque porque llevaba 15
años capacitando me para esto aun así
surgieron muchos imprevistos que tuvimos
que ir resolviendo pero fundamos nuestra
empresa
y eso que dicen de que cuando tienes una
empresa tienes que trabajar 12 horas al
día yo les puedo decir que en mi caso si
fue así si nos tocó así en nuestro caso
y que no hay vacaciones no hay fines de
semana no hay tiempo libre también les
puedo decir que así nos tocó tuvimos que
aprender mucho y seguimos aprendiendo
mucho y seguimos resolviendo problemas
pero cuando tienes los hábitos es más
sencillo si tu hábito es estar por
videojuegos estar en redes sociales no
vas a tener mucho más difícil porque hay
hábitos que son asesinos del éxito
porque todos queremos ser exitosos pero
somos desidiosos dejamos las cosas para
mañana porque son complejas son largas y
así vamos dejando que el tiempo pase
todos queremos ser exitosos pero no
somos directos no decimos que queremos
como lo queremos y para cuando lo
queremos nos da pena y nos quedamos a
medias todos queremos ser exitosos pero
no pedimos ayuda no queremos mostrar
nuestras debilidades y nos quedamos
callados
todos queremos ser exitosos pero no
queremos enfrentar los problemas no
queremos tener la conversación no
queremos enfrentarnos a la situación y
dejamos que las cosas sigan su rumbo
todos queremos ser exitosos pero no nos
capacitamos no nos renovamos hacemos el
intento leemos por encimita pero
seguimos haciendo lo mismo de siempre
tienes lo que se requiere para emprender
tienes que plantearte lo muy bien si
quieres ser doctor pero te da miedo la
sangre pues no puede ser doctor tienes
que forjar tu carácter
tu actitud tu tolerancia el riesgo no
solamente vas a ir a trabajar
va a ser liderar un equipo vacía motivar
un equipo y vas inspirar a personas para
que trabajen contigo si estás casado o
si estás casada tienes novio o novia
tienes que hablar con esta persona
y subirla a tu equipo que tu apoyo
porque requiere mucho sacrificio
cuando trabajas para una empresa
probablemente apliques al área que te
guste y eso te vas a dedicar más
aprendes si cometes errores no te cuesta
no tienes riesgo
como esta semana cobras tu quincena si
la empresa no te gusta te cambias de
empresas si te ofrecen algo mejor te vas
pero cuando tienes una empresa propia
eres el último en el eslabón de
prioridades en cobrar primero cobran tus
colaboradores después para tus impuestos
para su renta tus gastos tus productos
hace reserva de capital para crecer el
negocio y al final si queda algo cobras
tú tienes que dedicarte a todas las
áreas te gusten o no te gusten
[Música]
y tienes que tener tolerancia al riesgo
seguramente hayas invertido sus ahorros
hayas pedido prestado hipotecado tu casa
estás tomando decisiones día a día
que impactan directamente el resultado
de la empresa
pero si estás aquí si me estás
escuchando y tu norte y tu brújula
apunta hacia este destino adelante si
vale la pena es muy gratificante es muy
satisfactorio yo te diría sea atrevido
sé valiente no esperes a tener todo
planeado los planes van a cambiar los
vas a tener que rehacer el
perfeccionismo ese enemigo del
crecimiento y es tan importante 50 por
ciento importante ser inteligente que
ser atrevido las personas que son muy
inteligentes pueden ver los problemas a
cada acción que toman y muchas veces eso
los detiene por eso tienes que ser
atrevido yo conozco a mucha gente muy
inteligente que nunca dio el paso
no tengas miedo al fallo te vas a
equivocar muchas veces lo importante es
que te levantes aprendas rectifiques y
continúes no te equivoques dos veces es
lo mismo
mírate en el espejo que ves
mi esposa siempre me dice que yo soy un
gatito que se cree león
pero esta es la actitud que tienes que
tomar para que las cosas pasen
independientemente que trabajes para una
empresa o crees la tuya despierta tú ya
eres tu propia empresa y como jefe de tu
propia empresa
tienes que exigirle a tu primer empleado
que eres tú mismo nadie tiene que venir
a decirte qué hacer cómo hacerlo y
cuándo hacerlo mira tu brújula y
aprovecha tu tiempo tu energía tu
conocimiento para conseguir tus
objetivos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]